I always said that the whole point of
this meeting in Loch Erne is to fire up
our economies and drive growth and
prosperity around the world to do things
that make a real difference to people's
lives and there is no more powerful way
to achieve that than by boosting trade
and there's no better way than by
launching these negotiations on a
landmark deal between the European Union
and the United States of America there's
a special day for the relation between
European Union and the United States
today we announced we will start
negotiations of a comprehensive
transatlantic trade and investment
partnership agreement very frankly two
years ago very fuel they have bet that
today we'll be in the position to launch
negotiations of an ambitious European
Union United States free trade agreement
and when the teams of the European
Commission and United States will meet
for the first round of negotiations next
month it will be the start of a joint
undertaking of real strategic importance
as has already been mentioned the us-eu
relationship is the largest in the world
it makes up nearly half of global GDP we
trade about a trillion dollars in goods
and services each year we invest nearly
four trillion dollars in each other's
economies and all that supports around
13 million jobs on both sides of the
Atlantic and this potentially
groundbreaking partnership would deepen
those ties it would increase exports
decrease barriers to trade and
investment we both know there are no
magic solutions recent economic
turbulence and the lancets but we cannot
expect to harvest new jobs today we can
plant the seeds for the jobs of tomorrow
and that's exactly what the trade
agreement is about together Europe and
the United States are the backbone of
the world economy opening up that space
further for opportunities for business
and consumers is simply common sense not
just our own economies but also those of
our trading partners will benefit the
positive ramifications will even go
beyond the economy as such